all right so we're recording you Leila
yeah you got me know I had I had several
names at the time but lay low is one of
the names I used I had Danno
I had no name and I had lay low and the
reason I use this these names because I
was selling the dangerous drug called
fed No right when I first brought it
down here no one would touch it I was
living pretty dangerous because I was in
a school zone and I had to change my
name several times so everything I'm
talking about I already did time for it
so it won't be you know finished you
know one so I changed my name's a lot of
times you so the cops wouldn't know who
they was looking for they couldn't put
the name with the face that I had it was
six blocks nobody would touch that no
it's a very dangerous drug and
subsequently everybody would who touch
it and they wasn't familiar they
probably would die and fortunately I
didn't get anybody's you know I made
sure I distribute narcan to all the
people who use it if they got out of
prison and came to me I wouldn't I would
never sell to him I had like about most
workers I had was like 15 workers at one
time I had six blocks everybody know me
from here to to bakersfield to riverside
my name got pretty big you know I was
playing cat and mouse with the with the
cops a lot you know that's why I changed
the name lay low Danno and lay low you
know so they would didn't ever know who
they was looking for everywhere they go
out I'd be gone to the next spot because
it's hard to hit a moving target you
know so by me bouncing around and doing
different blocks
I was I was making substantial amount of
money that went away real fast I could
say I all made over $300,000 downtown
selling fed now over what period of time
in the about a year less than a year
I had a nice little run about eight nine
months I was going through like two or
three kilos I had the cars you know got
my mom cars and jury and all that but
she's the only one I ended up with
everything not me I ended up basically
with nothing you know it's a hard pill
to swallow because when you used to have
him that kind of money and then you go
down to basically nothing you had to put
your pride to the side it could destroy
you you know the car it was the
conviction that did it
yes yeah lost everything
I was married wife was gone reconciling
with differences she willing she locked
up on the money I sent her wish that's
the only person I could trust cuz you
when you make money like that you have
to trust somebody and she could she kept
all the money in his divorce me you know
they say when you down sometime they put
dirt on you you know and that's what
happened especially when it's coming to
drug money you know you know I lost
relations with my kids behind that
because I wouldn't stop they liked the
money but you know it just wasn't worth
it to me
you know I the only thing I really the
highlight of it is not send my daughter
to college I was able to get my oldest
daughter Candace through college she's
graduating next month as we speak she
got her doctorate and I says that's a
proud moment for me for being a a drug
dealer
you know everybody knows me down here I
you know I was pimping and selling drugs
and doing all kind of stuff you know but
I was able to get my daughter through
college I did something positive with
the money yeah and she graduates next
month she's been in college she's 17
she's 28 now and for the most part at
first I wasn't able to help her but I
took her to the finish line I'm proud
I'm a proud dad of that I don't know
what's gonna happen mind I see you next
month I might have a heart attack of
France Africa you know it's something
like dagger this is a proud moment for
me being a dad of five kids right and so
when you were sawing you were selling
just fighting all
other drugs too I was selling everything
they wanted
yeah from women to exercise crystal fed
non cocaine heroin whatever you want
each block consisted of something yeah
but my money was in the Fed no because I
was at one point I was probably the only
one downtown you can either get it from
five or ten dollars wasn't even an issue
you you had to have at least fifty
dollars or more to purchase that it's a
very expensive drug now they buying it
for like $5 you know s so that's another
reason I wouldn't want to get back in
there you know and and all the drugs cut
I had raw fed no you had to wear a mask
and if you touched it it could kill you
by the smell of it you have to have a
mass and when you open it it fumes go up
and just it's that strong it could kill
you the stuff they're getting down here
now it's all cut up but I had raw fed no
so but like I said I would monitor my
situation very carefully I didn't I
didn't get anybody's you know no that's
a good thing about it yeah do you tell
your customers I mean how do you feel
what's your role in the in the chain of
destruction that goes on here
yeah my role was go pick count the money
keep up with the money I had the workers
and but I always inform them to keep
giving narcan past narcan out you know
because the lowest bidder you get a body
you pretty much done I don't think
change your name would be able to save
you you know good fit now like I said
one one smell without consuming it could
kill you so my job was to get the money
but do you feel any responsibility when
you when you put your head on your
pillow at night you feel any
responsibility and what these people are
doing to themselves and all that yes a
whole extremely man I had a lot of
remorse about doing that I had when I
did my time I had a
long nights you know wondering what
happened to this person I happen to that
person but I said that drug can destroy
anybody reduce people the fentanyl never
I would never did introduce somebody if
they had to be doing it already and if
they just got out of jail they couldn't
get in there and I only allowed people
that smoked if I found out you shot fat
now I will not distribute it no nobody
that used the intervenors because it's
where it's for smoking but you can't
shoot it you know people use it for
muscle and purposes but the best way to
do it is to UM they say smoking that's
the safest way to do smoking so how did
you get arrested
Oh somebody told on me somebody in my
circle told on me uh they got a case and
they told him that give him somebody
right and so they did and I was getting
ready to leave as I was if I would have
been smart and left my money in the bank
instead of drawing it all out having a
going-away party because about a year
and a half ago I was having a going-away
party and they raided it and they got me
for over fourteen thousand dollars and
that was the last to laid on pretty much
right there that was my my personal
savings that I had and I draw all the
money out all my bank accounts and I was
having a going-away party and they raid
it
they raided my house my tent going away
we're going oh no up North Oakland where
my mom is
yeah I was just gonna go vacation really
but I was ready to quit because I had
what you call a tag and they were people
assigned to me whether I got said by me
changing the name but they didn't really
know who they couldn't put it together
as of yet but that's why it's called the
investigation because once they put it
together they like I said they tied me I
never got a direct sale I was very smart
to not to sell to anyone I did not know
I didn't take third party money if
someone that I know they don't have this
kind of money bringing that money to me
I would bury it until later on that
night then I get it because there's a
such thing as marked money that's one
way they have to get you you gotta have
the money the visual in the drug so I
was pretty I'm a critical thinker so I
was pretty smart not to have like all
those elements elements catch up to me
at one time and so when I got ready to
go out of town
they just mysteriously just raided the
party they found drugs over $14,000 and
gave me two years of half in prison I
did it right there in Los Angeles County
Jail the worst time of my life the
longest time of my life you know but
with my influence on the street I was
able to find a way up out of that
because you get a lot of favor and you
meet a lot of people and I'm a people
person so I I buttered a lot of hands
and I knew people saw in there I got a
couple of jobs and teacher's aide and
went to school and got my time cut off
like that
I had favor everywhere I went you know
right now the day people they know me
but I don't know them you know just
about anybody downtown they know they go
I put the mark down I just say I had a
pretty good run away you know they had
my minute of Fame in there and I did
nothing I did something nobody else did
you know I brought feting all down here
nobody would touch it
they were scared of it I took a chance
and I will end I don't say I'm sorry I
don't say I regret it I just regret that
people that hurt their self you know
what is the most popular drug currently
right now that no I know yeah eighties
and nineties it was cracked 80s and 98
was crack I had him running crack - I
started out selling drugs when I was
like 15 15 or 16 because I had to buy my
own school clothes so my mom tell me I'm
only gonna give you half you got to get
the rest so we had to figure out a way
to do it and how we did it was crack
cocaine no even in junior high in high
school I sold crack cocaine
it went from marijuana to crack the hair
when I found fitting art I mastered the
game because I did it when I was young I
just used all my elements from them and
so now I just applied all my you know
all my rules to the same thing and it
worked out just like that
but eventually you want to get you can't
get away with all good this comes to me
everyone gets caught right everyone
nobody gets away unless you know even
the people that that turn people in they
even got they they get they get caught
up to events you know just like they
told on somebody somebody else gonna
tell on them so it's just the same game
played in many ways and then when you
don't do the work whatever they want you
to do you like a piece of trash anyway
but one thing about me I always just did
my time you know no conversation I would
never talk yes I was my best customer
but I had so much I was buying a kilo at
a time so yeah I was using fentanyl I'd
use just about every kind of drug it is
and we are using salt no not today
I do how'd you get off a federal uh when
I went to prison here at the prison I
had no choice
well they give you a lot of they give
you a lot of pills though they give you
like 10 to 15 pills that'll help you out
plus I suffer from alcoholism and I had
it was addicted to heroin and fit not
all at one time so then when I went
there they would give me they had on the
computer and I was a chronic user high
tolerance so they give me like 10 or 15
pills are the best stuff they gave me a
vicodin you know colada pens you name it
they gave me all the good stuff that I
needed I was in a lot of pain that's the
worst kickin drug you ever it's ten
times thrown in regular heroin and fit
fitting I'll never lost a fight nobody
nobody can beat it where the chances of
you ever using you as merely human again
probably slim to none I'm 52 years old
I'm pretty much tired you know
I'll drink my liquor or whatever hard
drugs is just not for me
you know I want to live the rest of my
life peaceful see my daughter graduate
that's you know that's all I want to do
no too dangerous it'll kill you fast all
right babe oh thank you so much for
sharing your all right your story very
interesting yeah stuff man too much
you